ma voi sono tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sul gioco che non ho
mai fatto una mia vita oggi vi presento
dovete dargli una chance perché come si
dice i giochi magari ci mettono un
pochettino ad ingranare alle volte però
sono sicuro che se iniziamo a fare un po
di episodi su questo gioco qua potrebbe
avere successo si chiama happy wings
allora è un gioco dove tu utilizzi un
tuo personaggio e puoi fargli fare robe
splatterhouse adesso vi faccio vedere
vetta con questo qua ad esempio questo è
un vecchio anno dai partiti anzi
facciamo
finiamola con stack agata perché se non
ha un senso però l'importante è iniziare
bene ragazzi lo dico sempre infatti ha
fatto cagare prova be very very good
ero prima di vere ma perché mi sa che
devo da ecco la reggino io con gli altri
capito attenzione la tattica è buona
l'esecuzione pure però secondo padre che
va bene i miei piedi sono dio
però io voglio essere un super dio così
va avanti fa niente devo dice ma non
puoi andare più avanti di quello
vi rendete conto di questo vero non a
meno che non faccia così dal contrario
può essere solo se pero serve un try lo
faccio di più o di meno
prendi spin prendi pin eurospin
credo che così non lo so ragazzi non noi
grazie mille se il re dei tre your self
lo so perché una volta mi sono lanciato
con una red bull ma questo è un altro
video adesso lasciamo perdere anni
avanti su voltron basic
in che senso ha obesi normale ma fa
niente questo proprio easy questo lo
vinciamo subito ragazzi allora se avete
deciso di farmi girare i trequarti
ditemelo subito non è più possibile
non posso essere così scarso apporto che
è bello questo gioco promette bene con
robin guard perché hanno fatto una
persona è difficile i rock swing si può
fare ma porca vacca non sapevo comunque
porco demonio già le robe dell'inter un
po strano ma questa unione of swing è un
centro al buco swing si vabbè ma è
impossibile ma come fai a geniale dei
soci per mano mai fatta la rosa dai
allungati stacca a mano ce la fai
mi basta ragazzi toccarlo con qualsiasi
pezzo del corpo anche con il muco
starnutisci dai arcigay a questi mista
con la mano va bene fa niente lo
rifaccio che sono pigro non c'ha voglia
di rifarlo per favore mi sa che i miei
stessi problemi della vita che ciò io
non c'entro il buco dagli anni anni su è
prevista ancora non ha imparato a fare
cose
porca vacca dai allunga il piedino lunga
la scarpina niente ragazzi edificato
livello è veramente un casino non sto
scherzando
perché non avete idea di quanta
precisione ci voglia ma porca vacca vai
mi sono stampato la faccia per è stato
molto difficile parti schett profilo
bello spyphone epic o un po di spike col
fa sempre bene io credo che gli spike
siano livelli più sottovalutati di è
primis perché comunque ci vuole una
certa non è caduto non lo sciocco
andiamo avanti su
sì però stai calma siamo su un
impossible ragazzi voglio fare fatemi
sapere nei commenti se vi piace come
idea sono morto fatemi sapere se vi
piace di commenti come idea questa cosa
molto sincera vorrei fare questo in real
life nord vorrei fare un impossible
vorrei fare un video solo sugli imposti
voce un vino di happy vi si è incentrato
sugli imposti e credo sia la morte per
me però vorrei farlo magari il prossimo
episodio ragazzi che dite botto il flip
più colors no ma non c'è niente di
strano
porca vacca come ha fatto fini di sotto
a devo andare su win ma lo sai che non
ci si può arrivare libero come gliel'ha
spiegato è impossibile
hai un più 4 st nappa valore e un più 4
di uno oppure vinto non si sa come
bravissimo short di miss wing continui e
il nome inglese di duke però non lo vedo
ad hoc come si è fatto che figata
non aspettare che i ragazzi bellissimo
devo centrare solo lui che è molto
difficile ma belli ebbrezza che non
avevo mai fatta sta roba
vi giuro non mi ricordo di una volta che
ho usato uk per fare un rock swing c'è
solo lui è geniale si cimentavano come
così che noi siamo in venti metterai you
forza un rock swing solo tuo strada sta
roba ma funzionale a quanto pare va
molto bene e non dove non ci posso stare
così aiuto non ci posso stare così
scorso l'ho mancato fulcro quasi è
difficilissimo sembra facile ma è
difficile non mi toccare padre inutile
ma se lo faccio col padre cioè domanda
secca se lo faccio con lui che succede
me ne sbatto di luke proprio l'uomo
andato a morire
posso farlo con lui no tanto che cambia
cambia che non c'è spazio perché tutto a
misura di bambino però vabbè no non vi
sia staccata la lia nomi si è staccata
va bene in porto
ragazzi se questa non è la vittoria più
strana del mondo che vale come son
rimasto va bene va bene davanti ragazzi
camera di tortura questo livello family
friendly ragazzi tu che chi le cose che
succedono vedere bello sono io quando
tagliò le cipolle bello sono io quando
faccio la colonscopia questo sono io che
porto un 4 a mia madre dopo la scuola
questo sono io che rimorchio posso
decretare questo video family tre anni
secondo me non lo è addirittura treno
ogni ciak era va bene questo bello da
questo bellissimo ragazzi fermi tutti
per bersani ci stringe lo guarda
addirittura le spade attaccate con
l'attak e ce li ci siete messi d'impegno
poi coraggio mi piace suo livello carino
non può far niente
possiamo guardare soffrire le persone al
bund oggi quelle che non non riesco mai
a fare perché io la cosa che odio
dipinto gioco oltre luke sono gli
arpioni si va se non mi dici neanche da
dove passano ma poi sono quelli che sono
già piazzati monili devo intuire e
veneto qua e poi sopprimano fermo dal
frigo non passa niente
mamma mia ragazzi sono scampata bella
e ora grazie beirut
non so come ho fatto a schivarle tutto
anche perché non le ho viste sono andato
a culo però bene 89 per cento difficile
bello questo ovviamente livello diverso
papa cavalca però ho capito questa
indiana l'ho usata tre volte in mille
episodi che ho fatto
il problema è che non possa arrivarci li
devo lanciarmi come ci arrivo ti rendi
conto che vado abbastanza lento ce l'ho
fatta perché già corso farber posso
rientrare lì dentro che
verso il veicolo rientra bravo lo
aspetta non riuscirci
non so se ci si può rientrare bravo
prendi cappello ma non ci posso proprio
passare più perché c'è l'arpione che mi
mi sbarra la strada maledizione bravo
bravissimo
ok stavolta alla fine non c'è quindi se
guarda indietro ci dovrei fare
ahia vabbè lasciati va bene
[Musica]
aia ce l'ho fatta sono trascinarmi al
traguardo e borsa indiana bravissimo
l'ho usato una volta in tutto è primis
provi da sempre soddisfazione variabili
german suplex e vabbè allora aspetta ma
se la german suplex credo sia quella
dove lecchi tavoli e giusto ho mai
garroni di organi al play the wing
assassino e di fuori ahia cosa dovrebbe
essere questa cosa che sto vedendo
cercola questa german superstiti eccolo
finalmente l'ho fatta bene cioè male tu
che l'avversario però che per le persone
che sono depresse la tua pelle non è
carta non tagliarla la tua faccia non è
una maschera non coprirla la tua vita
non è un film non finirla samp siamo
tutti umani dobbiamo aiutarci a vicenda
ogni singolo umano e unico nel suo
genere non ucciderti perché sei
bellissimo tutti quanti sono vincitori
[Musica]
e una cosa veramente nobile su questo
non c'è assolutamente dubbio ma perché
su happy wheels forza la frutta sei un
jedi di star morta nel senso che col
pensiero io posso allora
è un frutta trovo bellissimo bampi cerca
il raid matteo e la madonna aiuto
va bene non pensavo così tanto mi sono
usciti piedi non fa niente posso andare
a casa ecco
cielo arrivato anche abbastanza intatto
e che mi sorprende va bene things paiono
più spies nel senso che devo fare un
rock singh più quello dove mi butto nel
mezzo bellissimo ma se io ho sempre
pensato di fare un livello del genere
non nessuno ha mai fatto parco
dell'oglio volevo farlo io
bravo e il nostro tornato indietro un
rock singh al contrario va dall'altra
parte molto più difficili quello che
sembra perché ho di lei troppo slancio
troppo poco
madonna guarda forse devo andare un pelo
più in alto sarà ecco esatto dai questo
è buonissima me ne vado sorgente meno
male perché mi aveva preso non so come
ho fatto a sopravvivere vabbè vabbè
ragazzi per me questo era l'ultimo
episodio normali di happy days non è
vero scherzo però prossimo episodio
fatemi sapere se volete che io faccia
quel 99 per cento impossible special
tutti livelli in una stagione per cento
fatelo sapere qua sotto nei commenti
bacino a tutti iscrivetevi al canale che
siete tosti iscriviti e non solo quella
bellissima campanella jaci vicino a
tutti mi disse di essere schiacciata
quindi schiaccia appena ragazzi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]